- So I'm here, and uh...
- So Jason, Busy tells me that you might
have some reservations about therapy,
and I want you to know
that I am going to be impartial, always,
because my job is to make things
better for the two of you.
Busy tells me that sometimes
you find her to be controlling.
- Uuhhh
- I think that's fair.
- Yeah. Okay, yeah, sometimes
I do find her a little controlling.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, well that can be a tough thing
and believe it or not, I'm that
way with my wife sometimes.
- Oh! Yeah!
- Shoot! You know what I'm
sorry, I think I left my phone
in the waiting room. I'm just
gonna grab it, two seconds.
- Come right back.
- I will, of course.
- C'mere. C'mere! Listen
dude, I want you to know
that I totally have your back, okay?
No matter what is said in
here, I'm on your side bro.
Okay? Do you know what I'm saying?
- What do you mean?
- What do I mean? She's in her own world!
Look, we're a coupla guys.
Dudes back each other up.
Okay? We're dudes. I'm gonna back you up.
- Oh no no, you don't have to do that.
- No I'm going to do it.
- No no no. That's okay.
- Shut up. Here she comes.
(Busy clears her throat)
- [Busy] Oh gosh. Sorry. Embarrassing.
- Any calls? Everything okay?
- Oh no, I just didn't want to leave it
because I have lost like, four phones.
- [Dr. Glen] So Jason, go on.
- Um, well, yeah, she's a
little controlling sometimes
and that, you know, I just, kinda,
it feels like it encroaches
on my freedom a little bit.
- Mmm hmm. Do you feel that's
an accurate characterization?
Do you feel that sometimes you
are controlling with Jason?
- [Busy] Well, yeah, I mean to be fair,
we have two children,
we have a lot of responsibility.
I'm the one that, I mean...
- She makes all the money.
- Right. I'm over here,
I'm doing this thing,
and I'm over there and
I'm doing that thing
and I'm parenting the
kids, so when I ask you
to pick up milk it's not an order,
it's not me being
controlling when I ask you
to come home at 10:00 p.m.,
as opposed to staying out til three.
- Right, right, I'm working
when I'm out that late.
I mean I'm like doing stand-up, or I'm--
- I mean like hanging out in
a club is work, I don't know.
- [Jason] Yeah.
- [Busy] I don't know.
- A big component of your job,
as I understand it, is hanging out.
There's a social component
to stand-up comedy
that is, uh, it's being in those clubs,
and that's a big part of
how connections are made.
Getting work and securing future work.
- I just haven't thought of it that way.
- That's right.
- That it was more making
business connections.
- You know I'm sure you would be able to
tell Busy that there's an unpleasantness
to this hanging out, you wish
you could be home sometimes,
but then it's all part of the business.
- You see why I wanna
come? Isn't he the best?
- He's the best! This
is great! Doctor Glen!